According to two studies, one done at the
Ataturk University in Turkey (in 1991) and
another at the University of Manchester in
England (in 2006), both dogs and cats are
typically right or left pawed.
According to the Ataturk University study,
the majority of domestic cats are right pawed
(50%), 10% of them are ambidextrous, and the
remaining 40% favor their left paw.
Dogs, on the other hand, according to the
University of Manchester study, tend to be
more evenly split with around 50% being left
pawed and 50% being right pawed, with a statistically
insignificant number being ambidextrous.
In addition to that, there seems to be a connection
between the gender of the animal and which
paw is dominate in both cats and dogs.
Specifically, female cats and dogs typically
will have their right paw be dominate, while
males tend to go with the left paw.
However, if the animal has been spayed or
neutered at an early age, this distinction
goes away.
Determining if your cat or dog is left or
right pawed or ambidextrous isn’t as simple
as running one test, such as giving them a
toy to play with just out of their reach and
seeing which paw they reach with.
This is because their paw preference is often
weekly expressed, unlike with humans.
Thus, in order to accurately determine your
pet’s paw preference, you need to run such
tests several dozen times to see the trends.
Some helpful such tests for dogs and cats
include: if you’ve taught your dog to shake
hands, which paw do they seem to like to use
the most?
If your dog or cat is playing on its back
and you put your hand just out of their reach,
which paw do they reach for your hand with?
You can also try putting a treat or a toy
just out of their reach underneath a bookshelf/coffee
table/couch /etc. and see which paw they typically
try to reach for the treat or toy with.
You can put some peanut butter on the top
center of their nose and see which paw they
use to get it off with.
For both dogs and cats, if the animal wants
inside or into a room you’re in, which paw
do they typically use to scratch at the door?
Another good one is to put a treat underneath
something and see which paw they use first
to try to uncover the treat with.
Yet another test is to place a small piece
of paper or plastic on a smooth surface so
it can slide, and then place a tasty, lickable
treat on the paper.
When the dog or cat licks it, inevitably the
paper/plastic will slide and they will likely
use one of their paws to stop it from sliding
while they lick.
In all these cases, record which paw is used
and once you’ve done several dozen such
tests, check to see if there is a clear dominate
paw.
If not, continue on until one emerges.
If you’ve done 100-200 or so such tests
and there is no noticeable paw preference,
your animal is probably ambidextrous.
That being said, it should be noted that cats,
as in all things, tend to be trickier to figure
out than dogs.
For instance, it’s been observed that when
cats are playing, they typically don’t exhibit
much in the way of paw preference, but when
they want something, like a treat, it’s
then that they’ll usually use their dominant
paw first, unless they are simply one of those
10% or so that are ambidextrous.
Bonus Facts:
• Horses also can be left or right hoofed
or ambidextrous.
While for cats and dogs their paw preference
is fairly inconsequential, for race horses
particularly, knowing this information can
be very important.
For instance, in horse racing in America,
horses run counterclockwise and when turning,
turn to the left, so which hoof is their dominate
can be important in that, “You have to work
to get them to take the lead they prefer less,”
says Dr. Sharon Crowell-Davis at the College
of Veterinary Medicine at the University of
Georgia.
For courses where the horse has to turn multiple
ways, an ambidextrous horse then is more desirable
than one who has a hoof preference.
• There is a cat who loves playing the piano.
(And for the record, she’s right pawed,
though uses both paws to play and even sometimes
uses her head to play more notes when her
paws are occupied on other keys.)
The cat is named Nora, owned by Betsy Alexander
who is a piano teacher.
Nora enjoys playing the piano on a daily basis,
even sometimes playing duets with humans.
She first started playing around a year old
and has continued to this day, even being
filmed playing when no one is around to hear.
You can see a video of this here in the link
in the show notes.
• The idea that people who are left handed
are naturally disposed to evil has been around
for as long as we have recorded history.
The Devil is mostly portrayed as left handed.
The Bible mentions right handedness positively
over 100 times, while left handedness is mentioned
only 25 times and every time is negative.
• Domestic house cats are known to be able
to fall from any height without suffering
fatal wounds most of the time, even when landing
on concrete.
You can learn more about this in episode #93
of this podcast.
• The longest lived domestic cat was named
Creme Puff.
She lived from August 3, 1967 to August 6,
2005, a span of 38 years and 3 days.
This is well over double the normal life span
for domestic cats, which is typically around
12-14 years for males and 13-15 years for
females.
Interestingly, the owner of Creme Puff, Jake
Perry, also raised a sphynx cat which was
born in 1964 and didn’t die until 1998,
a span of 34 years and 2 months.
The cat’s name was “Grandpa Rexs Allen”.
Why Perry’s two cats lived so long isn’t
entirely known, however, he didn’t usually
feed them store bought cat food.
Rather, he raised them on a variety of “natural”
foods; prominent among these foods were: bacon,
eggs, asparagus, and broccoli, among other
things.
This can be a somewhat dangerous practice
normally as cats require certain nutrients
they won’t always get if they are just eating
“human” food.
For instance, cats will go blind fairly quickly
(and permanently) if they don’t get enough
taurine, found in muscle.
Cats also require a high amount of protein
and calcium to maintain proper health.
This high amount of protein consumed by cats
is thought to be why dogs like cat poop so
much, with it being very protein-rich.
• The documented record for the most kittens
born to one cat is currently held by a cat
named “Dusty”.
She gave birth to 420 kittens in her lifetime
and even had a litter at the very old age
(for a cat) of 18 years old.
• The most kittens in one litter is 14,
a feat accomplished by a cat named Bluebell.
Amazingly, all 14 kittens survived, which
is rare in large litters of kittens.
• The smallest adult cat on record was named
Tinker Toy. Tinker Toy as an adult cat weighed
just one pound, eight ounces and measured
in at just 2.75 inches tall and 7.5 inches
long.
• The heaviest cat in the world was 46 pounds
and named Himmy.
This cat had a waistline of 33 inches.